[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir ce soir nous
venons vous dire au revoir car nous
partons en vacances ressources est bien
triste de vous quitter
et moi aussi ça ou ils peuvent pro mais
vous le savez nous reviendrons le plus
vite possible vous retrouver et nous
aurons des tas de belle histoire à vous
raconter givel patron oui il descend
vite nounours et en bracelet bien fort
de ma part hop là
moi avec ce chapeau j'ai très près par
rooney est comme ça je n'aurais pas des
taches de rousseur
moi j'en porte pas de chapeau quand je
vais bronzé comme un bon soir les
enfants je lis le joli chapeau
c'est pourquoi faire tout ça arrive et
nous c'est pour partir en vacances et on
va bientôt partir au bord de la mer il
faut une dose pour marquer ce soir avec
ulysse ou est ce que tu veux en vacances
chez ma maman à moi il y il est invité
ma maman l'a invité il vient avec moi
alors vous voit plus de convoyant non
nous aussi on prend des vacances pendant
tout l'été
mon patron est très fatigué il a besoin
de reprendre bonne mine et et moi aussi
j'ai maigri de 500 grammes ou qui nous
est à la rentrée nous serons de nouveau
en pleine forme
ma maman va nous gâter viendra à nouveau
pendant le vol quand on met tous les
soirs ulysse jettera quand même un petit
peu de sable dans le ciel pour que vous
vous endormirez vite et comme vous êtes
bien sage
vous irez vous coucher tout seuls comme
des grands
oui papa il dit qu'on est très grand et
qu'on va aller à l'école et on va prêter
de petites choses des langues étrangères
ok pas ton tout minutes ce mort iam
coming du lot c'est pour apprendre ça
moi je vais pas le col
alors c'est promis vous serez bien sage
pendant notre absence et vous tous aussi
les petits enfants oui c'est pramil
nounou qui gérait le juré plein de
ressources
on a fait un beau cadeau pour tes
vacances
[Musique]
oh merci les enfants un bon bikini c'est
vraiment gentil je le mettrais pour me
baigner et un gros pot de miel comme ça
tu penseras non merci les petites
minutes
je le partagerai avec ulysse et nous
penserons tout le temps à vous allons
les enfants il faut que je m'en aille en
dormez vous bien sagement
nous y tête à la lumière oui oui voilà
au revoir mes enfants chéris à bientôt
à bientôt
[Musique]
oh
jamais nous voir ulysse pas les belles
vacances pour voir petit louis au revoir
petite mirabelle passer de belles
vacances et soyez bien gentil et vous
aussi les enfants n'oubliez pas d'aller
vous coucher bien sagement chaque soir
et nous reviendrons bientôt vous voir je
ne sois pas triste nos sources
car les petits enfants savent bien qu'on
reviendra vite qu'ils ne sont pas
tristes double accord pas trop mais je
les aime bien moi ce petit tout est en
ordre pour notre voyage eux où ils pas
trop tout alors en route on voir tous
nos amis et à bientôt
bonne nuit bonne nuit
[Musique]
on